they also did a bonus episode on tiger
king our bowl our boy Joel McHale host
of it Oh Joel really but it's all like
FaceTime with all the characters I hate
FaceTime interviews and [ __ ]
Joel did the best he could he's pretty
funny on there but it's just I would say
we're all in a room together because I
wanted the chaos there saying Joe exotic
he's always wanted Fame and he's like
the most famous person on earth right
now but he's locked in a cage they're
saying the irony of it how about he
admitted to killing those Tigers the
healthy Tigers in prison he admitted it
oh yeah but didn't weren't they sick or
something
no that's when they do they're like he
said they weren't sick he just needed
the space so he killed these healthy
Tigers Shaun he'd called him up to the
cage and shot in the face
in the head I shouldn't say face yeah
that's what happens when you have 300
Tigers and it cost $300,000 a year or
something to feed him but here's what
attention every one of them were as
friends they all go does he deserve to
be in jail every single one of them said
yes every single one go yes yeah he's a
lot of bad things yeah he's a bad guy
yeah it's a bad guy yeah he's [ __ ] yeah
he's awful and the people around him
were not awful they were kind of they
were not bad people
it seems how about how about his
boyfriend the one with the meth teeth he
has all new teeth now good for him he
has a fiance who's out who's a girl yeah
he's not gay that's right he's just
messed up oh he's a good-looking guy huh
excuse me
well with his teeth line all right the
good-looking guy it's not a bad-looking
guy here with T and then Hilma psychics
ugly you're not getting o with teeth I
mean not good if you cover his mouth
he's not a bad-looking dude
in fact he's beautiful beautiful
we gotta have that beard over here so
tall that he's got terrible ideas of
what the good looks good on his face no
like no T's Dennis dear dusting here's
what's interesting to that one kid who
committed suicide they came out said it
wasn't suicide suicide by accident he
had a gun he's messing around you didn't
know there's one in the chamber and cuz
the guy who
commit suicide city was messing around
didn't his chamber we pulled it he said
for about five seconds saw the look in
his eyes like oh [ __ ]
died maybe I already killed himself you
know we don't know well I mean they
would say it this this guy came out was
like no I saw it not from the expression
his eyes after our bullets got in his
head you can't tell you oughta watch it
because it came out to this accident but
I hope it was I mean if you want to play
those tiger so bad he's willing to suck
dick there must be a great time to do
who is that guy which one
Geoffrey Charles Djou second husband I
don't know not just give another this
okay people have sent me crazy [ __ ] that
Joe exact used to make people have sex
with the Tigers and all sorts of ones
that they're not possible you'd be
surprised on boy really yeah what do you
do push your [ __ ] against the cage
and put sardine oil around your hole how
do you get a tiger to [ __ ] you you [ __ ]
the tiger homeboy love that tail good
luck with that I'm sure well they're
awfully sedated dude oh she said hanging
to it dude about [ __ ] and Tiger Joe
exotic man yeah what about another guy
which one Jeff oh he still run the zoo
Jeff flow is that zoo overrun now with
[ __ ] sightseers and people they must
be making a for in quarantine right so I
can't go out in there shut down but it's
nice I hear where you're going well is
uh so they were so I I thought you
weren't allowed to are you not allowed
to breed Tigers anymore is it still
allowed did that I don't yeah I don't
know cuz apparently they're all pieces
of [ __ ] when you talk to the one guy he
goes now you know all these people and
they all run these lion or tiger
sanctuaries he owes is is Carol is it
Karen Baskins Caravan El tiro bastions
he was she actually helping people you
just stop they're all the same they're
all making money off these poor Tigers
all the same it's all [ __ ] show yeah she
was they just cover at different ways he
was all to say of course Travis the nine
piece who went to play with Tigers so
bad
dick such a bomb that's a bummer
apparently Joe exact has a bunch
episodes on YouTube Eunice watch heard
they're fascinating heard they're been
in the documentary she's just some wild
[ __ ] Travis I know dresses Deborah Jones
otic oh he does he used to have a
YouTube channel and there's a shitload
of stuff on that have you got ahead of
your Luke torch in I saw that that's
where I found a music video I'm not sure
if I saw his actual YouTube or his music
YouTube yeah I don't know
you know his boyfriend came out said he
definitely wasn't singing those songs
that's hilarious
that's so funny man God Joe exact TV and
I think that's where all the videos
100,000 subscribers that mean blew up
recently for sure they said it's the
biggest documentary of all time they
believe that is it really I think so
well that's what I kept saying do you
think of it well making a murderer that
was pretty big yeah but Tigers are yeah
was fast
well Joe exotic [ __ ] the time the Tigers
the Tigers yeah he's been a million
tiger you have amazing characters an
tigress you have Joe exotic dude yeah
he's the he's such a witnessed here in
our system Jay his boyfriends husbands
chillin Tigers you learn all these
meters trying to kill other people I
wonder how you can figure out the
biggest documentary of all time owner I
wonder what would compete with that I
don't know there's been some great
documentaries man like because Netflix
doesn't release any views or anything
well they do you have no idea how you're
special does Oh Chris Dula special drops
tonight at midnight
sweet kids probably watch it tomorrow
morning tonight at midnight I'm sure
this is not recent thaw 15 most of
you've got but Netflix won't give them
them yeah that's another problem too
going clear was a big one
Food Inc was huge this is 50 tosser
these are faked this is [ __ ] these
are 50 documentaries that these dorks
watch and may decide about you know what
I can find out though
I don't know weird Netflix underneath
any numbers like you shot a special on
there and let's say you went from doing
clubs to arenas you like well I'll see a
shitload of people watched it yeah you'd
like to know those numbers yeah they
don't tell you no Tigers apparently
Tigers are much safer to work with then
chimpanzees Lions why because Lions have
hurts and tigers are by the rods yes
since birds but if they hurt they don't
have hooves
but prides and a pride of lions
apparently lions are very intelligent
because I have to read social cues from
each other and their hierarchal they
have you know CAD so so when you come in
and you got a limp or you come in and
you got you know you're not you're not
giving them like solely heat this guy
who trains tiger says when you bring
people in the cage you let the tiger
greet you you let the tiger do his thing
and it's like well I mean I'm sorry the
lion greet you because the Lions are
very cute and socially they're very cute
into what you're doing and the kind of
signals you're giving them whereas
Tigers are not that way and they're
different I don't want to be around in
these [ __ ] animals
I'm just never touch why I feel like
it's a matter of time before you're
gonna get [ __ ] you know something's
gonna happen doesn't make sense to me
nope it doesn't but there's something
amazing about danger that's why human
beings like - why do you climb k2 where
1 in 4 people die why tires are the same
thing you'd the juice of it the feeling
of I'm the only person that can do this
I'm gonna be down to climb k2 but I
wouldn't be down to flush the guide the
[ __ ] guys got a king cobra as a pet a
king cobra as a pet let me say pet guess
what he you what happens is you go the
guy knows snake after for three years
after a year whatever I'm comfortable
around saying I'm I now - pick it up and
I'm comfortable you know what I'm casual
chip op bite you the guy goes well I'm
gonna put the caged snake back in I'm
gonna
I'll just drive I'll Drive myself to the
[ __ ] you hear him on the thing he
goes I got bit by a king cobra had to
pull over I can't see I'm going blind I
need something that's right another
woman she got bit by a king cobra same
thing she's a herpetologist she goes MA
that's crazy got bit
she puts the snake back in she takes
care of some things around the house
before she goes takes care of some
things
don't ask then decides to drive her she
died well she died of the venom yeah
that's right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]